Monsieur le Premier Ministre chers
collègues nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui Monsieur Manuel
Valls en tant qu' ancien Premier
ministre du 31 mars 2014 au 6 décembre
2016 monsieur le Premier je vous
souhaite la bienvenue je vous remercie
de vous être rendu disponible pour
répondre à nos questions aujourd'hui
dans cette assemblée vous connaissez si
bien vous le savez à partir du 18
juillet 2022 plusieurs membres du
consortium international des
journalistes d'investigation on publie
ce qui est désormais convenu d'appeler
les uberfils s'appuyant sur 124000
documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine d'été de 2013 à 2017 cette
enquête a déhancée à lobbying agressive
de la société uber pour implanter en
France comme dans de nombreux pays des
véhicules transport et chauffeurs des
VTC venant concurrencer le secteur
traditionnel du transport public
particulier de personnes réservées
jusqu'à leur au taxi
dans ce contexte notre commission
d'enquête est deux objets d'une part
identifier l'ensemble des actions de
lobbying menées par uber pourra
s'implanter en France le rôle des
décideurs publics de l'époque et mettre
des recommandations concernant
l'encadrement des relations entre
décideurs publics et représentants
d'intérêt d'autre part pour ambition
d'évaluer les conséquences économiques
sociales environnementales du
développement du modèle uber
l'ubérisation en France et les réponses
apportées et à apporter par les
décideurs publics en la matière dans la
mesure vous avez été premier ministre
ministre de l'Intérieur puis Premier
ministre lors du conflit entre les taxis
et les VTC entre 2014 et 2016 après
l'arrivée du beurre sur le marché
français votre témoignage vous assemblée
indispensable pour vérifier l'effet
révéler par les uberfiles les uberphail
sont mis en évidence 17 échanges
significatives entre uber et le cabinet
du ministre de l'économie à l'époque les
articles mettent en évidence que
l'entreprise a pu exposer ses arguments
et tenter d'obtenir des modifications
législatives favorables au développement
de son modèle d'affaires en outre les
articles expliquent je cite aurait été
conclu entre le ministre d'économie et
uber après accord avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve nous avons
reçu le premier ministre Cazeneuve en
audition ce matin ainsi que l'ancien
ministre des Transports à l'infidéliste
qui nous ont tous les deux confirmés
qu'il n'y avait pas eu de Deal et
qu'aucune décision de l'époque
concernant la réglementation des VTC les
lois étaient venus les lois grand
Guillaume les règlements n'avaient
échappé à
l'interministériel mais vous pourrez
nous nous confirmer cela
les questions principales donc que nous
souhaitons vous poser sont les suivantes
de quelle manière votre gouvernement
a-t-il traité la crise entre les taxis
et les VTC la crise entre les chauffeurs
VTC et plateformes telgüber entre 2014
et 2016 pouvez-vous préciser s'il y
avait des divergences entre une liste de
l'intérieur des transports et de
l'économie si elles étaient opaques si
elle faisait l'objet de dissimulation de
la part des uns des autres si elles
étaient au contraire assumées
transparentes dans le cadre d'un
dialogue interministériel classique lors
de la première crise de 2014 ayant
conduit à nommer monsieur thévenou comme
médiateur lui avez-vous transmis des
consignes en amont pour privilégier
plutôt le maintien du monopole et taxi
l'ouverture à la concurrence du parti
d'une partie du marché des VTC
et enfin selon vous les différents
acteurs
que ce soit vous-même et les ministres
du gouvernement ont-ils pu opérer sans
pression en transparence au nom de
l'intérêt général on kiffé l'objet de
pression de la part de lobbying ou
d'autres acteurs nous aurons bien sûr
d'autres questions à vous poser mes
collègues mais je vous propose d'entamer
notre discussion à ce stade en répondant
à ses premières questions en vous
laissant bien sûr la parole pour votre
propos immédiaire je rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole monsieur le Premier je
vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958 relative
au fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité avec la vérité je
vais donc vous inviter à activer votre
micro levez la main droite et dire je le
jure je le jure monsieur le président
ce Président Madame l'a rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
d'abord c'est un plaisir et un honneur
et puis
je ne peux pas me soustraire et je ne
voudrais pas me soustraire à votre
invitation j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
faire quelques reprises notamment il y a
quelques semaines pour la Commission
concernant
la les problématiques de souveraineté
énergétique il est normal de de répondre
aux attentes aux questions du Parlement
quand on a été en fonction comme je l'ai
été au ministère de l'intérieur ou
comme premier ministre
peut-être un peu dans le désordre plus
une approche une réponse à vos questions
en sachant que
je vais essayer de m'en tenir d'abord au
fait parce que je ne peux répondre sur
ces sur ces sujets là mais plus
difficiles de répondre à des élévations
ou les informations
qui ont été publiés par la presse il y a
quelques mois et qui était suffisamment
sérieuse pour qu'elle provoque une
commission d'enquête comme comme la
vôtre d'abord ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il n'est pas un congru
c'est un propos un peu limitaire que des
échanges entre des sociétés des
entreprises et en l'occurrence la
société Hubert et les pouvoirs publics
a eu lieu
et que ces échanges en l'occurrence ce
soit priothétairement déroulées à Bercy
dans la mesure où la principale valeur
ajoutée de ce type d'entreprise
consiste dans le design d'une
implication numérique de mise en
relation entre prestataires et clients
bien sûr il y avait des impacts sur des
professions traditionnellement régulées
ailleurs au ministère des Transports au
ministères de l'intérieur mais la
problématique plateforme numérique
surtout au milieu de la décennie
précédente où c'était émergentes étaient
d'abord traitée à Bercy
et par le secrétariat d'Etat au
numérique placé sous la responsabilité
du ministre de l'économie ou les
dossiers numériques étaient enracinés de
longue date c'était donc la logique des
choses
avec le recul on voit bien qu'il y avait
un mouvement d'innovation une demande
croissante du public avec des effets
positifs et négatifs évidemment c'est
d'ailleurs dommage que des acteurs
européens puissants dans le domaine des
transports je pense au taxi par exemple
n'est pas anticipé cette aspiration
technologique avant qu'elle n'arrive et
qu'elle s'impose ou qu'elle bouscule
le marché dans ce secteur d'ailleurs et
bien d'autres
troisièmement Hubert à l'évidence
a eu des pratiques ne font pas attendu
les révélations c'était les pratiques
qui ont marqué l'actualité
Hubert a donc eu des pratiques et un
comportement
à la hussarde pour utiliser un mot un
peu général en choisissant une politique
du fait accompli et avec peu d'égards
pour notre droit
ce n'était nullement propre à la France
cela a été pratiqué partout dans le
monde mais avec un budget global de
lobbying très important je crois autour
de 80 millions d'euros
Hubert avait décidé de s'attaquer un
marché important le deuxième si je me
trompe pas qui était la France les
autorités de l'époque on cherchait à
mettre en place des
des digues protectrices de certains
équilibres sociaux comme par exemple la
tentative de différenciation entre le
service de taxi l'immédiat et les VTC la
réservation avec un quart d'heure
minimum de temporisation mais les
tribunaux et le juge constitutionnel
n'ont pas suivi il a fallu se rendre à
l'évidence d'un besoin d'évolution
je veux dire également il faut prendre
garde de ne pas tout reconstruire pour
le seul plaisir du débat politique
8 à 10 ans après l'effet mais
l'émergence de plateformes a changé
incontestablement le mode de
consommation des citoyens le mode de
consommation des véhicules à la demande
et d'ailleurs a aussi accéléré dans les
grandes villes la baisse du taux
d'équipements de certains ménages en
véhicules individuels
et puis enfin il faut reconnaître qu'il
était nécessaire d'une manière ou d'une
autre de libéraliser le secteur de VTC
je reconnais que des bas parfaitement
légitime sur ce type de choix qui avait
été
traditionnellement très corseté en
France
alors évidemment cela ne s'est pas fait
sans heures
aujourd'hui mais peut-être que je n'ai
pas moi bonne distance en tout cas bonne
vision sur ce qui se passe désormais
les deux professions coexistent ou sont
côte à côte
et contrairement à ce que certains
avaient pu pronostiquer à l'époque
les taxis n'ont pas disparu bien au
contraire j'ai le sentiment que à Paris
par exemple ils sont plutôt les gagnants
je n'ose pas dire les gangs gagnants de
cette période et peut-être même que
l'offre me semble de meilleure qualité
je fais enfin un rappel non pas pour
minimiser nos débats mais que peut-être
vous me reprendrez
le secteur des taxis et des VTC certes
est important mais de doit représenter
que un pourcentage minime de l'offre de
transport en général peut-être autour de
3%
[Musique]
les pratiques du Berre
s'inscrivaient d'abord dans une culture
je vous apprends absolument rien de
start-up américaine dans une culture
technologique et économique strictement
structurellement pardon agressive et en
compris très tôt dans les années 2010 le
fait le phénomène alors émergent des
plateformes la valeur économique et la
puissance de marché qui réside dans les
faits réseau et les faits je traduis
directement en français le gagnant
remporte tout donc c'était en effet une
attitude agressive Hubert et d'autres
plateformes ont dès leur pratiqué le
bisme agressif dans un certain nombre de
pays je l'ai déjà dit ou le marché a
conquérir était appétissant avec un
certain cynisme il suffit de lire
d'ailleurs l'audition de Monsieur Marc
mcgain
qu'elle vous avait procédé pour s'en
rendre compte je trouvais que ça ça
avait au moins l'avantage d'une forme de
sincérité sur les pratiques
très financé par le capital risque
américain à l'époque presque exclusif la
France d'ailleurs a rattrapé son retard
depuis notamment grâce à l'implication
personnelle celui qui était ministre de
l'économie à l'époque Emmanuel Macron
ils ont pu
ces plateformes se faire assister des
moyens considérables donc de nombreux
avocats pour détecter les failles
législatives de nos pays respectifs la
France n'est pas échappé et de lobbyiste
pour expliquer défendre leurs causes
mais ils sont pas parvenus à leur fin
par la seule manœuvre ils ont aussi
saisi anticipé plus vite que d'autres
des tendances de fonds liées aux
évolutions numériques économiques
parfois il arrive aussi que le
consommateur vote avec ses clics en
quelque sorte on peut le regretter mais
on peut pas esquiver totalement ce type
d'évolution le ministre de l'économie de
l'époque en allant au contact de ces
acteurs c'était ça sa conviction
cela pouvait susciter parfois des débats
mais c'était sa vision d'une économie
qui est en train qui était en train
d'évoluer a pu aussi en tirer des leçons
sur
la façon de développer l'économie
numérique
je souligne avec le plus grand respect
qui n'a pas tout inventé la french Tech
qui a 10 ans doit beaucoup à Nathalie
kosciuskumoricet ou à Fleur Pellerin
chacun a su apporter de nombreuses
pierres un édifice qui rend d'ailleurs
dans ce domaine-là me semble-t-il la
France aujourd'hui plus forte et pour
moi c'est ce qui comptait c'est ce qui
compte encore aujourd'hui avant tout
cependant je veux être là aussi clair je
n'ai jamais fait mienne
vous faire sourire la thèse d'un nouveau
monde merveilleux face à l'ancien monde
qui serait ringard en l'occurrence je ne
parle pas de politique seulement mais
j'évoque le monde du Berre face à celui
des taxis et prendre Hubert pour se
déplacer se faire livrer un repas par
délivroux
louer son appartement par
NBA c'était des phrases d'Alain Vidal
Alice ce n'est pas à mes yeux le monde
idéal même si je suis conscient des
changements de consommation
deuxièmement la précarité offerte aux
jeunes de banlieue non plus et c'est
vrai que là nous avions un débat avec le
ministre de l'économie qui considérait
que ce secteur est extrêmement porteur
d'emploi notamment pour des jeunes non
qualifiés vous pouvez avoir le débat moi
je me rappelle c'est de vous parler le
plus franchement possible disons que
dans le secteur des transports
il y avait des offres faites on le fait
pour beaucoup de jeunes conditions qui
passent leur permis de conduire etc mais
dans le secteur des transports je me
rappelle que dans l'agglomération que je
présidais avant d'être ministre à Évry
c'est vrai aussi à la RATP c'est vrai
aussi dans le secteur des taxis on
trouve souvent plus souvent ces jeunes
ou ses origines de quartier ou de
départements donc la précarité même si
c'était une réalité au-delà de ce
secteur qui existait ne pouvait pas être
une politique qui
s'impose et enfin
nous étions évidemment je crois tous
d'accord la concurrence fiscale déloyale
avec des entreprises qui ne paient pas
l'impôt en France
ne peuvent pas être non plus notre tasse
de thé pour parler de manière familière
enfin
vous avez auditionné vous venez de le
rappeler Bernard ce matin un avis
d'Alice vous a livré également sa
version il s'est d'ailleurs énormément
impliqué et il avait déjà fait des
erreurs dans un livre très intéressant
qui s'appelle ministre souffrançois
Hollande sous-expérience ministérielle
et notamment sur celle-ci
le conflit entre taxi et VTC est connu
de longue date et il préexistait là
aussi vous le savez à mon entrée au
gouvernement en 2012 depuis le rapport
Attali de 2008
et surtout depuis la création par le
Parlement en 2009 d'un secteur
dérèglementé de véhicules de tourisme
avec chauffeur sur réservation qui a
conduit
au triplement de l'offre VTC comme élu
de la grande couronne parisienne j'ai
fait allusion il y a quelques secondes
j'avais bien perçu le caractère aigu des
enjeux sociaux pour la profession des
taxis d'ailleurs des impacts
différenciés entre les artisans
propriétaires les salariés et la
puissance économique particulière
représentée par exemple comme une
société comme la G7 j'avais conscience
aussi que l'évaluation que l'évolution
des modes de consommation et la montée
en régime des plateformes nécessitait de
faire évoluer les choses pour rendre un
meilleur service aux usagers si l'on
prend l'exemple de la région parisienne
il était quasiment impossible de trouver
des taxis en grande banlieue
un détail
en tant que ministre de l'Intérieur je
n'ai pas eu à gérer
directement
à ce moment-là je dis parlent entre 2012
et 2014
le secteur ou des conflits dans ce
secteur mais je savais que l'inquiétude
était palpable
et que
il y avait des risques de de dérapage
sans doute qu'à l'époque mon cabinet du
ministère de l'Intérieur n'avait des
contacts réguliers c'était normal dans
ses missions avec avec ce secteur
je n'ignorais pas qu'avant l'arrivée sur
le marché du Berre et d'autres sociétés
du même type une licence de taxi à Paris
par exemple ses cheveux s'achetait aux
environs de 250 000 euros et je cite
cela uniquement là aussi je pense ne
rien vous apprendre cela permet de
comprendre les difficultés financières
des taxis dernières entrants confrontés
brutalement à une concurrence de
nouveaux acteurs sur le marché qui
n'avait aucune licence à amortir et qui
en plus ne respectait pas les règles
spécifiques à la à la profession
ce problème des licences et d'ailleurs
c'est invité à de nombreuses reprises
notamment dans les réunions que nous
avons eu en début 2016 lorsque j'ai pris
mes fonctions à Matignon le député
Thomas thevenou terminé sa mission de
concertation
je n'avais pas eu de message de mission
à lui à lui à lui transmettre avant dans
un sens ou dans un autre
et l'examen de sa promotion de loi était
enclenchée en mode accéléré signe que
chacun au gouvernement comme à
l'Assemblée nationale
considérer déjà le sujet comme
urgent
nous savons tous que sa loi celle qui
porte son nom visait à répartir les
rôles entre les taxis et les VTC la
maraude pour les pour les uns
l'obligation de réservation pour pour
les autres après l'adoption de la loi
techno
force est constater que la situation ne
s'est pas vraiment apaisée car sans
doute que sans doute la question était
plus large que celle des seuls taxis et
des VTC il y avait celle du covoiturage
qui montait en puissance et faisait
concurrence aux autres acteurs celles
des transporteurs dit lotis la loi de 82
réputé réservée aux transports de
plusieurs personnes à la fois et bien
sûr celles des Hubert des plateformes de
mise en relation qui se développaient
dans les grandes capitales avec
notamment le service uberpop le célèbre
service uberpop qui était une forme de
covoiturage payant illégale et qui a
finalement été interdit il a fallu
réagir fermement suite à les incidents
graves en juin 2015 le ministre de
l'Intérieur de l'époque là évoqué ce
matin je crois devant vous j'y
reviendrai évidemment
en janvier 2016 avec Alain vidalis nous
avons confié à Laurent ganguillaume une
mission de concertation de nouveau dans
le but d'apaiser de faire émerger les
meilleures solutions de nous aider
d'ailleurs à faire émerger les
meilleures solutions le travail de ce
jeune parlementaire qui était doté d'un
vrai sens du dialogue il nous reste
sensibilité sociale il a montré sur les
territoires zéro chômeurs aussi a
conduit là aussi à l'adoption d'une loi
à la fin de de la même année les
arbitrages ont été pris à chaque fois
j'espère avec écoute en analysant les
positions des différents ministères
chacun des fondant
ces visions
et elle reflète je crois la direction
que je souhaitais donner à travers
l'action de mon Gouvernement sur ce
sujet sensible à savoir
la défense d'une offre de transport de
transports individuels de qualité pour
les usagers fondés sur deux piliers une
offre de taxi plus ouverte
professionnelle transparentes et avec
une qualité renforcée et des plateformes
de VTC avec des conducteurs mieux formés
et exerçant leur activité dans un cadre
davantage régulier et une transparence
sur leur tarification je veux terminer
sur les questions de méthode avant de
répondre à vos questions
tout au long ce sujet
évidemment j'ai consulté de nouveau mes
anciens collaborateurs n'a jamais été
suivi exclusivement par un seul de mes
conseillers mais toujours par trois
conjointement afin que ce soit toujours
concilier la pluralité des points de vue
et des intérêts meilleure manière de
suivre ce que vous appeliez à juste
titre le travail interministériel ainsi
de conseiller transport le conseiller à
faire intérieur et un conseiller
économique
ont systématiquement piloté à trois les
réunions avec des ministères et cette
organisation rendait impossible je crois
très sincèrement toute collusion et les
intérêts particuliers ou tout angle trop
exclusif en août les sujets n'ont pas
été laissés à la seule conduit de
laministration au cabinet nous avons
voulu je le répète
qu'on ferait aussi un regard politique
au traitement de ce dossier on nous
assurant le concours de parlementaire
nous avons déjà cité
donc le gouvernement de l'époque a tenu
associer le Parlement la définition et
la conduite de la politique des
transports de personnes individuelles
le 28 janvier 2016
afin de ménager une sortie de crise
après des manifestations de part et
d'autre virulentes mais notamment des
taxis
j'ai reçu tous les acteurs la Matignon
avec du ministre de l'Intérieur Bernard
Cazeneuve et le ministre chargé des
transports à l'individualis Emmanuel
Macron n'était pas là pour des raisons
d'agenda mais je suis certain que son
cabinet était directement présent à
cette réunion
nous avons examiné également l'hypothèse
d'un rachat complet cela faisait partie
de nos réflexions avec indemnisation des
licences de taxi parce que j'étais
soucieux que le développement des VTC ne
ruine pas ce qui constitue un actif pour
la retraite des artisans et puis je
percevais la difficulté à maintenir des
régimes juridiques étanches entre des
professions qui font au fond un métier à
ses proches avec des pratiques
différentes évidemment face au
coûtentiel pour les finances publiques
face aux difficultés sociales de mise en
oeuvre cette idée a été abandonnée sans
doute avec un peu de pragmatisme au
profit du mécanisme des licences
incessibles mais là aussi fait
comprendre
j'insiste nouveau profession de taxi il
fallait se moderniser dans les systèmes
de réservations améliorer la qualité de
service
je me suis impliqué
évidemment personnellement la période
était pas facile vous pouvez le
comprendre vu ce qui a marqué l'année
2015 et c'est le rôle du Premier
ministre d'être à peu près sur tous les
sujets je me suis personnellement
impliqué en tant Premier ministre dans
la gestion d'un conflit social dur
avec des expressions parfois dramatiques
s'exprimer par
les taxis mais aussi du côté des VTC
avec le respect de femme d'hommes qui
effectuait au fond
certaines métiers de contact
mais un vrai service public
nous avons une réunion de plusieurs
heures non sans tension
et de gueule
nous avons aussi fait le choix de
regroupement et de transfert des
compétences au ministère des Transports
je crois que c'était un bon choix pour
suivre et traiter ces questions bref la
politique de l'époque a pris en compte
tout le secteur et n'a pas été obnubilé
par le seul cas de l'emprise
uber bien évidemment et c'est pour être
complet
mon dernier mot puisque vous avez fait
allusion
j'ai bien lu aussi les déclarations à ce
sujet je n'ai jamais eu connaissance
d'un deal
en 2015
je l'aurais pas accepté
il faut se souvenir que les atteintes à
l'ordre public avec des agressions
physiques dans de nombreuses villes
Paris Lyon Marseille
ces atteintes étaient nombreuses graves
intolérables
nous tenions à ce que la situation
respective des taxis et des VTC évoluent
de façon raisonnable de la mesure de
possible nous avions fait ce choix là
d'autres pays d'autres villes ou
d'autres régions en Europe ou dans le
monde on fait parfois après le choix de
l'interdiction avec d'ailleurs situation
différente selon les les pays vous ne
serez pas étonné de vous dire que par
exemple
dans la ville de Barcelone pas loin de
l'interdiction avec des conflits très
durs ça n'a pas été le cas à Madrid ça
reflète peut-être des orientations
politiques mais pas seulement des
histoires
conflits très dures à San Francisco ou à
Bogota pour sortir de l'Europe également
eu lieu
mais la chose très claire c'est que je
veux souligner une nouvelle fois si nous
ne pouvions pas accepter une concurrence
totalement déloyale et illégale
et l'arrêter pour mettre fin à Hubert
pop
était pour nous une priorité
Bernard Cazeneuve l'a rappelé sans doute
ce matin il agit avec une grande fermeté
les arrêtés d'interdiction du père pop
ont été pris en juin 2015 et
pour cette interdiction
pour les arbitrages rendus en 2016
d'ailleurs j'étais pendant le seul
pendant toute cette période mise en
cause de manière virulente dans des
articles de presse ou sur les réseaux
sociaux qui étaient alimentés à
l'évidence j'ai retrouvé
de presse très intéressante qui était
alimentée à l'évidence par par Hubert
mais il me semble que c'était le drôle
nous avons tenu bon sur cette ligne de
crête et sur les choix sur l'idée que
nous faisions à la fois de la profession
des taxis et des VTC et c'est ça qui me
permet de conclure cette première
intervention luminaire et cette première
réponse à vos questions monsieur le
président
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre donc
vous nous l'avez dit effectivement il y
avait une situation qui
touchait tous les grandes économies au
fond et peut-être en particulier la
France parce que entre autres le secteur
des taxis était très régulier n'avait
peut-être pas à l'époque apporté les
adaptations nécessaires à son modèle qui
depuis a évolué avec par exemple les TPE
on en a beaucoup parlé c'est d'un
semaine
et donc si je comprends bien vous nous
dites que
toutes les décisions qui ont pu être
prises durant cette période
avec pour essayer de tenir cette ligne
de crête comme vous voulez dire
on fait l'objet d'une concertation au
fond assez classique au sein du
gouvernement avec les différents
ministres impliqués ministres des
Transports ministres de l'économie
ministre de l'Intérieur qui ont pu
s'exprimer et décisions après fait
l'objet de de décision interministériale
aucun ministre ne pouvait sur ce sujet
qui touchait trois ministères prendre
des décisions des arrêtés seuls contre
d'autres membres du gouvernement
je vous le confirme
[Musique]
mode interministériel
le fait que
ce sujet était suivi par des ministères
pas seulement des ministres
qui pouvaient avoir des positions
différentes égards à l'histoire du
rapport de ces ministères avec cette
profession
en l'occurrence cela peut paraître
étonnant la relation du ministère des
Transports avec le secteur des taxis et
ensuite des VTC étaient assez faibles
nous l'avons renforcé je crois que
c'était logique de le faire
le mystère de l'économie
s'emparer depuis peu de ces de ces
sujets je l'ai évoqué je ne répète pas
et le ministère de l'Intérieur avait une
tradition liée souvent d'ailleurs à
celle de la préfecture de police de
Paris de rapport avec les taxis qui
remontent sans doute à d'autres à
d'autres temps comme s'il y avait pas
d'autres villes en France qui avait des
taxis mais
il fallait mener gérer ce travail
interministériel et donc logiquement
comme c'est le cas c'était au cabinet du
premier ministre il y a ce dernier de
faire les arbitrages merci je voulais
vous poser aussi la question de la
représentation des différents acteurs
taxis VTC
j’étais venu la semaine dernière nous a
dit que il avait pu travailler sans
pression sans consigne d'ailleurs comme
vous l'avez confirmé
rencontrant tous les tous les acteurs et
au fond elle dit même s'il n'avait pas
été influencé dans son travail il avait
bien pu voir que tous les acteurs
faisaient preuve de pression de méthodes
de lobbying uber évidemment c'est
l'objet de la commission d'enquête mais
aussi les taxis en particulier les taxis
G7 puis vous avez mentionné aussi les
mouvements de violence qu'on a pu voir
dans dans les rues lorsque nous avons
rencontré Monsieur Rousselet taxi G7 il
nous a confirmé d'ailleurs lui-même sans
problème avoir accès à l'époque aux
différents
dirigeants publics est-ce que vous avez
pu observer
ces méthodes de lobbying de la part des
différents acteurs est-ce qu'il vous ont
eu selon vous un accès équivalent au
fond au décideur public de l'époque
pendant cette période
comme ministre de l'intérieur ou comme
premier ministre moi je n'ai pas
constaté de pression dans un sens ou
dans un autre
au-delà de ce que j'ai pu lire l'été
dernier où il y a quelques mois
mais je ne t'ai plus en fonction à ce
moment-là
[Musique]
mais pas à ce moment-là je me somme
contentés de deux sources ne sont pas
négligeables d'abord je le répète le
travail interministériel et puis d'autre
part les rencontres
que j'ai eu moi-même une essentiellement
avec avec le secteur et puis il y avait
évidemment le travail parlementaire
celui de Thomas thévenou je l'ai
évidemment vécu dans sa dernière phase
il est d'ailleurs lui-même rentré au
gouvernement sur un tout autre sujet
malheureusement il est pas resté très
longtemps pour d'autres pots d'autres
raisons et ensuite avec Alain vidaliste
nous avons suivi plus attentivement
encore le travail qui était mené par
Monsieur ganguillaume
je fais cependant une différence de
méthodologie le secteur des taxis et
donc des grandes entreprises comme la G7
avait pignon sur rue je le dis dans le
bon sens du terme c'était les
interlocuteurs presque classiques des
partenaires de l'administration voire
des cabinets
moi je l'ai pas eu à rencontrer à
l'époque directement ou indirectement
ces acteurs sinon dans des réunions
parfois se sont passés ou une réunion
essentiellement c'est passé avec une
certaine une certaine tension je faisais
différents et
de nouveaux acteurs notamment un qui
émergent dans le marché et qui se
comportent de la manière dont il s'est
comporté bref je fais la différence
entre
l'action d'entreprise ou de syndicats ou
de groupements qui défendent leurs
intérêts
il appartient aux politiques et
l'exécutif ou législatif de faire
prévaloir dans la mesure du possible
l'intérêt général et de l'autre côté
de nouveaux acteurs qui souhaitent
s'affranchir des règles ou imposer une
certaine vision qui n'est pas totalement
celle qu'en général nous défendions dans
notre dans notre pays mais en tout cas
moi je n'ai pas eu assoupir
dépression particulière dans un sens ou
dans un autre
une dernière question de ma part pour
l'instant plutôt sur les débats
contemporains puisque c'est évidemment
un des objets de notre commission
d'enquête les conséquences de
l'ubérisation vous avez fait allusion à
l'Espagne cette un pays dont on a parlé
à plusieurs reprises lors de cette
commission d'enquête qui a imposé une
présomption de salariat notamment sur la
question des livreurs est-ce que vous
voyez aujourd'hui puisque vous avez
souligné que c'était un débat qui avait
lieu dans beaucoup de pays des pays qui
ont adopté d'autres modèles qui vous
paraissent peut-être aujourd'hui plus
appropriés est-ce que le modèle espagnol
le présente son salariat pourrait être
selon vous un précédent en France en
particulier au moment où nous sommes en
train d'avoir au niveau européen un
débat sur une directive de présomption
salariat pour les plateformes
de la directive qui est
je vais être honnête avec vous grâce à
vous
j'étais obligé de me pencher davantage
sur le sujet grâce à vous je veux parler
de la de la Commission et de cette
invitation
de ce que j'ai pu comprendre de je parle
sous votre contrôle
cette directive a pour objectif là
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
des individus exerçant une activité via
une plateforme
et elle permet d'instaurer vous l'avez
dit un mécanisme de présence de
salariat si certains des cinq ou sept
critères non arbitré à ce stade
prédéfini sont constatées et encadré
améliorer la transparence de la gestion
algorithmique du travail puisque je
pense que c'est le vrai sujet auquel
nous sommes confrontés et nous le seront
davantage dans l'avenir alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a un certain nombre de pays
Portugal l'Espagne la Belgique etc les
Pays-Bas aussi qui sont favorables à ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une ligne ferme
dure qui entraîne une requalification
quasi automatique et systématique vers
le salariat
il souhaite se mécanisme de présomption
du salariat qui puisse déclencher dès
que deux critères sont sur 5 sont
constatées et il y a des positions
évidemment différentes ce n'est pas
nouveau pour ces concernent l'Union
européenne avec des pays qui sont
opposés à la
requalification massive et puis il y a
des positions plus intermédiaires comme
la position allemande ou la position
française
j'espère ne pas vous étonner pour vous
dire que je me sens davantage proche de
la position française même si je
comprends au vu de ce que j'ai vécu les
positions plus dures comme celle du
premier groupe que
j'évoquais mais la position française de
ce que j'ai cru comprendre là aussi
elle cherche à préserver la nécessité de
de créer des géants numériques européens
qui créeront de la valeur numérique en
Europe et de mieux protéger évidemment
les salariés les travailleurs de ces
secteurs ce que je crois c'est que
l'unification du marché européen
est nécessaire
pour l'éclosion de ces champions
européens et je regrette d'ailleurs mais
mais je le dis avec beaucoup d'humidité
parce que je suis quand même de très
loin cette discussion je regrette des
divisions ou des prises de distance
entre ta membre
que cette discussion soit bloquée
pour savoir s'il faut deux trois ou
quatre critères pour définir la
présomption de de salariat
je suis pas étonné par le fait que
s'affrontent des traditions
régularitrices de basculement
automatique des travailleurs des
plateformes via une requalification du
salariat et de tradition plus libérales
que je pense très sincèrement c'est
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière ce que
nous avions en tête au moment des faits
qui qui m'amène devant vous ce qu'il
faut essayer de préserver la force d'une
économie nouvelle et de l'autre
le statut des des salariés et si la
France a une position médiane entre ces
différents blocs
il me semble que le plus urgent c'est
d'adopter une position une directive au
niveau de l'Union européenne
et que le droit change et qu'il devienne
plus protecteurs pour les salariés donc
unification du droit et protection pour
les salariés
c'est peut-être le fruit la foi de mes
convictions mais aussi de mon expérience
que je vous donne en répondant à votre à
votre question
oui bien sûr
oui monsieur le Premier ministre je
voudrais quand même revenir sur
sur la période des révélations des
hubert-files
a posteriori après toutes ces années
passées avec donc beaucoup plus de recul
sur les événements n'avez vous pas le
sentiment que la focalisation
du débat sur la plateforme uberpop qui
était finalement le paroxysme de
la concurrence totalement déloyale et
faussée par rapport à la profession de
taxi puisqu'il s'agit c'est pas
simplement d'avoir des chauffeurs VTC
pour lequel la carte VTC
ne coûte que peu de 150 euros quand un
chauffeur de taxi
doit mettre parfois 250 000 euros dans
une licence les différences sont encore
d'autres ordre la tarification du taxi
fixé par exemple pour Paris par la
préfecture quand Hubert pouvait
régulièrement vraiment finalement faire
un dumping et casser les prix puis très
rapidement il a augmenté en augmentant
sa marge en opérant une pression mais du
coup une
concurrence très forte sur le prix de la
course qui leur permettait de de
s'imposer sur le marché et une période
pour les taxis c'était extrêmement dur
d'autant plus quand évidemment arrive
uberpop mais n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment que la focalisation du débat
autour du père pop a permis à Hubert de
gagner du temps et que finalement il y
avait une stratégie de
de lobbying par uber qui était horizé
comme la stratégie de la violence il le
théorisait il trahiskalanique
s'en faisait le le maître et assumait de
d'organiser la conflictualité sur le
terrain de cette compétition pour
pouvoir mieux imposer sachant que leur
objectif était non seulement de de ne
pas respecter les réglementations
vigueur dans tous les domaines droits du
travail
concurrence fiscalité enfin tous les
niveaux mais avec la volonté que cette
état de fait qu'il imposait puissent
modifier l'état de droit mais est-ce que
vous avez pas eu l'impression le
sentiment à posteriori que la
focalisation sur uberpop
n'a peut-être pas permis de prendre la
mesure de la concurrence déloyale mis en
place par Hubert tout court
avec le recul madame la rapporteur le
il est évident que à ce moment-là ce
n'était pas totalement nouveau mais nous
faisions face à l'émergence d'une
nouvelle économie qui nous venait
essentiellement d'autres Atlantique pas
seulement et qui est en train de gagner
le monde
et qui possède des vrais problèmes
politiques économiques sociaux éthique
mais qui aussi bousculé le marché et
obligé à réagir
c'est obligation de réaction
concernait bien sûr les pouvoirs publics
les élus mais le concernait aussi les
entreprises qui devaient faire face à
cette à cette concurrence
mais
en réfléchissant de nouveau et votre
question intéressante
m'y oblige à voix haute je pense que
cette ligne de crête en tout cas les
arbitrages que
ministérielles et les textes de loi
de cette époque ont permis
précisément d'offrir des solutions de
transport
plus diversifiée plus complète pour nos
citoyens tout en préservant les métiers
et les spécificités de chacun et des
taxis en particulier
en tout indépendant je le répète à
chaque fois
et moi j'ai le sentiment peut-être on a
perdu du temps peut-être qu'il y a eu
des manœuvres je veux bien le croire
plus le temps politique le temps de
l'exécutif le temps législatif est
toujours long par rapport à des
pratiques qui elles épousent les
nouvelles formes de communication mais
non je pense que nous avons traités par
les déclarations très ferme des
ministres qui était sous ma
responsabilité les miennes aussi et par
les choix que nous avons fait nous avons
bien répondu nous avons répondu à
ces pratiques
brutales
parfois illégal de cette société et
d'ailleurs quand
je lis
ce qui a été publié il y a quelques mois
la presse de l'époque
où les comptes rendus de votre
commission
plutôt le sentiment que ces acteurs là
Hubert en l'occurrence
se plaignait pas avoir véritablement du
côté
du Premier ministre mis de l'intérieur
c'est normal côté de l'Elysée il y avait
rien à dire
se plaignait plutôt de l'absence de
réponse et surtout du fait que ils
étaient très loin de leurs objectifs et
de leur et de leur but
vous avez
réaffirmé en début d'audition qu'il n'y
a pas eu de Deal et pour nier tout dit
qu'il aurait pu avoir entre
le gouvernement et Hubert sur l'abandon
de la plateforme
uberpop en échange d'assouplissement des
exigences en termes de formation pour
les chauffeurs VTC dans les documents
révélés par les hubert-féles et
transmises par à la presse par le
lanceur d'alerte Marc Magan on a
plusieurs éléments qui
montrent des échanges très fréquents
avec le ministre de l'économie de
l'époque Emmanuel Macron autour de ces
sujets
et également une une stratégie en tant
que tel une stratégie qui était actée en
deux temps un temps désamendements
à l'Assemblée nationale
pour essayer de déconstruire de
détricoter la loi thévenou qui certes
avait été adopté mais n'était pas
appliquée d'ailleurs ne l'est toujours
pas aujourd'hui il y a pas de retour au
garage des chauffeurs VTC et la maraude
électronique se poursuit bien de fait
dans les faits
et ensuite la volonté d'intervenir sur
sur la formation moi je voudrais
vous lire des exemples de
de SMS qu'on a pu avoir dans ces
échanges là notamment un message de Marc
Magan qui transmet à ses collègues à
l'intérieur du Berre suite à des
rencontres donc avec avec Emmanuel
Macron et son cabinet
la discussion avec Emmanuel Macron lors
du rendez-vous de Bercy apporter sur la
déréglementation des WCC à savoir
l'abaissement des barrières à l'entrée
qui limite l'offre 250 heures de
formation entre 4000 et 6000 euros pour
une licence il souhaite que nous lesions
en communiquant de manière claire et
agressive sur le fait que le prix à
payer est celui des VTC un système de
licence VTC Lite permettrait une réelle
création d'emplois et d'opportunités
économiques donc on a d'autres messages
de ce de cet ordre là
qui qui montre que
que
Hubert est très satisfait des relations
qu'il peut avoir en tout cas les
dirigeants humains sont très satisfaits
des relations qu'ils peuvent avoir avec
avec Emmanuel Macron sur sur les
éléments
sur la prise en compte en fait de leur
préoccupation alors de deux choses l'une
je pense qu'il est tout à fait possible
que le premier ministre de l'époque que
vous étiez ainsi que le ministre de
l'intérieur ainsi que le ministre des
Transports ne soit pas au courant des
communications qu'il y a entre le
ministre de l'économie et les
plateformes
et que vous ayez découvert ces relations
là au moment
au moment des révélations uber-files
mais lors de vos échanges et de vos
discussions est-ce que vous confirmez
néanmoins qu'Emmanuel Macron était sur
une position qui n'était pas du tout
celle du ministre de l'intérieur et du
ministre des Transports et qui comprit
dans le débat parlementaire s'affronter
à l'intérieur même du groupe dans lequel
vous étiez le groupe socialiste de
tendance est-ce que vous voyez à ce
moment-là aussi des amendements des
stratégies d'amendement telles que les
hubert-félices nous le nous le révèle
d'amendements qui ont été soit soutenus
indirectement par des proches de Macron
soit transmis même directement par par
la plateforme uber est-ce que vous voyez
ces expositions de cette manière là
je vois le sens de votre question
je parlerai pas des positions et des
tendances au sein du groupe socialiste à
l'époque
elles étaient effectivement très très
nombreuses alors
moi je ne t'ai pas au courant de ces
échanges que vous évoquez qui ont été
révélés mais
je le répète je l'ai dit au début comme
l'intervention limitée
de l'économie et des relations des
rapports avec des entreprises
dans cette économie émergente qui
cherche à s'imposer ou à offrir leurs
services j'emploie un mot neutre dans
notre pays moi cela ne me choque pas
l'idée de cette relation
moi j'ai pas eu de rapport direct ou
indirect avec ce avec ce secteur
j'ai interrogé mes collaborateurs je le
dis en passant l'ensemble de mes
collaborateurs qui suivaient ces
questions là ils m'ont dit qu'il
n'avaient eu
aucun rapport direct et que personne
n'avait été reçu la Matignon d'ailleurs
ça n'aurait pas été un scandale
peut-être peut toujours le vérifier
encore de de plus près en tout cas
monsieur Marc Magan mais c'est pas le
sens de votre question n'a jamais été
reçu à Matignon lorsque j'étais Premier
ministre et j'ai interrogé d'ailleurs
celle qui était ma directrice de cabinet
à l'époque
suite au déclarations que Monsieur Magan
a fait devant votre commission elle
n'avait aucun souvenir
d'une réunion ou d'un rapport direct ou
indirect avec avec Hubert je ne fais que
rapporter des propos
j'ai évidemment une grande confiance
dans dans ce qu'elle me dit et dans
l'intégrité qui n'est pas à démontrer
qu'il a qui est la sienne donc que ces
rapports aient lieu au niveau de Bercy
au niveau du ministre de l'économie moi
ça ne me pose pas de problème
deuxièmement
les faits c'est ça qui évidemment
m'importe avant tout
moi j'ai pas eu connaissance
d'un travail particulier
de lobbying
auprès des parlementaires
de pression
d'amendement déposé donc Bernard
Cazeneuve a répondu aussi ce matin et
surtout d'un aboutissement d'ailleurs de
ce de ce travail
auprès des
députés en l'occurrence socialiste
dans beaucoup de secteurs dans de
nombreux domaines des députés entre 2002
et 2018
arrivé de recevoir telle association tel
secteur je m'échappe la du secteur
concerné des amendements et d'ailleurs
parfois pour de bonnes causes
pratiquement rédigé j'ai jamais beaucoup
aimé cela parce que c'est une forme
d'intrusion dans le travail
parlementaire mais cela existe qui plus
est là où sapin régule déjà depuis un
certain nombre d'années ce type de
pratique et on interdit d'autres mais
encore une fois moi j'ai pas eu
connaissance à l'époque et d'ailleurs
[Musique]
Laurent ganguillaume qui suivait ses
sujets là vous l'avez auditionné je
crois il va être auditionnel donc il
vous le dira bien mieux que moi
était extrêmement respecté au sein du
groupe majoritaire au sein du groupe
socialiste et cela m'étonnerait lui et
puis laisser passer que ce soit laissé
impressionner par tel ou tel amendement
ou tel ou tel pression qui ait pu
s'exercer
donc alors
est-ce que cela a donné des résultats en
particulier
est-ce qu'on a
allégé par exemple
des contrôles sur
uber ou d'autres plateformes VTC c'est
d'ailleurs une des questions il m'était
posée non
non en revanche avec l'aide d'un moteur
de recherche très connu j'ai retrouvé
les articles de presse relatant des
décisions strictement inverse de mon
gouvernement suite au conflit social de
janvier 2016 c'est-à-dire que compris au
fur et à mesure permet d'apporter un
élément à votre question précédente
au fur et à mesure du déroulement du du
conflit parce qu'il a duré un effet
plusieurs mois plutôt le sentiment moins
que la position du gouvernement
a été de plus en plus
ferme vis-à-vis de ces pratiques alors
et je termine je suis trop long pardon
Emmanuel Macron
défendait des positions
je pouvais les partager parfois sur la
loi travail par exemple
[Musique]
défendait ses positions
à la fois comme ministre de l'Économie
je dis pas qu'il y a un jeu de rôle des
ministres enfin
parfois quand vous êtes à l'économie
vous défendez les positions un peu
différentes de celles du ministère de
l'intérieur où les transports ou à la
défense vous défendez pas tout à fait
les positions du ministre du Budget
pas où faire la vie quotidienne à
Matignon cet après-midi mais il
défendait par conviction
et parce qu'il était ministre de
l'Économie un certain nombre de
positions qui étaient une un regard
attentif ou vert assez
nouvelle économie qui était en train de
surgir toutes ces positions à l'époque
sont connues étaient connus il n'y a
aucun aucun mystère lui et son équipe
défendait évidemment une plus grande
libéralisation
de ce secteur au nom même je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure
du potentiel que cela pouvait créer pour
notre économie pour l'emploi
pour des secteurs de la population peu
qualifiés qui pouvait la trouver une
voie
positive mais aussi pour l'image de la
France
aussi pour l'image de la France donc et
si position il les a défendues au sein
du Conseil des ministres dans les
réunions interministérielles ou dans des
forums nationaux ou internationaux mais
il était dans son droit et dans sa
position mais ce qui a ce qui comptait
de mon point de vue
ça concerne et ça concerne tous les
membres du gouvernement c'est que les
arbitrages soient rendus en fonction des
choix que nous avons fait
que je faisais sous l'autorité du
Président de la République donc moi je
n'ai pas eu à me plaindre ou à ressentir
des positions qui nous mettrai en
difficulté que parfois la discussion a
été rude
foi poli et respectueuse de chacun c'est
normal mais se déroulait dans dans
l'enceinte ou dans la discrétion ou
sinon dans le secret des discussions
entre ministres autour du Premier
ministre
il y a clairement à ce moment là une
position idéologique clairement assumée
par Emmanuel Macron et qui ne date pas
de ce moment-là il a été
le rapporteur aussi de du rapport
Attali sur la libération de la
croissance qui a amené à la création du
statut d'auto-entrepreneur la loi
Novelli donc il y a une cohérence dans
la volonté de tout libéraliser
il ne s'agit pas de remettre cela en
cause il s'agit à travers les
révélations uberphales s'interroger sur
la portée de tous ces échanges
extrêmement
régulier et fort entre une plateforme
américaine par ailleurs hors la loi sur
bien des domaines et un ministre en
exercice
avec des messages
extrêmement important je vous en lien un
autre car de Marc Magan qui écrit au
ministre n'oublions pas quand même
à qui l'écrit désolé de vous embêter
mais il y a une descente en ce moment
d'une vingtaine de fonctionnaires de la
Direction des finances publiques ils
disent qu'ils vont mettre les dirigeants
en garde à vue leur mandat taxation de
Hubert V qui gère tout Hubert dans 50
pays nous avions espoir de pouvoir
atteindre le fameux climat d'apaisement
dès ce weekend pouvez-vous demander à
vos services de nous conseiller merci
Marc Magan on a d'autres échanges de
cette nature là où le ou ils essaient
d'intervenir face aux face à un nouvel
arrêté pris dans les Bouches-du-Rhône
enfin il y a plusieurs échanges et
parfois des réponses du ministre
Emmanuel Macron qui peuvent être ces 600
concernant par exemple les
l'arrêté pris par le préfet du nez des
Bouches-du-Rhône de l'époque Emmanuel
ainsi que ceux du ministre de
l'Intérieur et des transports
peuvent nous peuvent attester de
l'opacité qu'il pouvait y avoir entre
les relations du ministre de l'économie
et du Bert puisque vous n'en avez pas eu
connaissance
a priori vos collègues confirmaient ce
que vous laissez entendre que dans
l'arbitrage ministériel vous n'avez pas
vous vécu d'influence et de pression
indirecte provenant de ces lobbies ou
exprimer tel quel par Emmanuel Macron et
concernant le déballe parlementaire sans
doute était-il entre guillemets plus
loin
de là où on exerce le pouvoir pour
pouvoir le réaliser
néanmoins avec le recul
on peut se dire que Emmanuel Macron est
donc minoritaire à l'époque n'a pas
réussi soit obtenir les arbitrages qui
promettaient à Hubert
ou bien alors pour d'autres raisons que
j'ignore à volontairement menti à Hubert
en leur faisant croire qu'il allait
qu'il allait véritablement défendre
leurs intérêts parce que quand même ces
engagements qu'il prend dans ses
messages sont forts aujourd'hui avec la
loi Sapin 2
est-ce que vous pensez que ces éléments
là ne seraient serait impossible quelle
recommandation de par l'exercice
l'expérience que vous avez de
pour avoir assumé les fonctions de
Premier ministre qu'elle recommandations
vous pourriez faire à la Commission dans
au service d'une meilleure séparation
des lobbies de l'État monsieur Cazeneuve
et Monsieur vidaliste ayant néanmoins
exprimé à quel point il pouvait être
choqué par ce type de de relation où ils
ont eux je reprends les propos de
Cazeneuve a dit clairement qu'on n'a pas
à négocier avec une entreprise hors la
loi
moi j'aime le débat public politique
aucune question ne me choque mais venant
de parlementaires dans le cas d'une
commission d'enquête elles sont
parfaitement légitimes suite aux
révélations que l'on causé
création
cependant
j'étais Premier ministre je parle pas en
termes d'autorité mais j'ai exercé des
responsabilités importantes pour mon
pays dans des moments particulièrement
difficiles notamment évidemment face au
terrorisme
Emmanuel Macron est aujourd'hui le
président de la République élu et réélu
et donc je fais très attention non pas
mon propos
parce qu'il est libre mais à ce que
mes propos ici
je vous parle très franchement madame la
rapporteur de participe pas d'une joute
politique ou d'une volonté même si je ne
mets absolument pas en doute
votre volonté manifeste de connaître les
fêtes
connaître toute la vérité sur ces sur
ces révélations moi je ne veux pas ou je
ne peux pas
c'est au moins l'avantage des anciens
Premier ministre
participer de de cela
je le répète il était logique que le
ministre de l'économie est ces relations
ce rapport avec des entreprises peut
toujours avoir un débat sur le contenu
des SMS ou des WhatsApp et SMS plutôt à
l'époque sur leur fréquence
sur ensuite l'interprétation que fait
cette société et ces dirigeants qui
peut-être se poussent un peu du col
il se donne une très grande importance
alors qu'ils sont eux-mêmes en
difficulté face aux décisions qui ont
été prises jamais le ministre de
l'économie de l'époque il savait qu'il y
avait un endroit
où on pouvait en tout cas essayer
d'exercer c'est normal la pression de sa
conviction c'était le bureau du premier
ministre jamais le ministre de
l'Économie
m'a demandé dans un sens ou dans un
autre mais de remettre en cause
les choix de l'administration des
enquêtes ou de laisser faire ce qui
était vous avez parfaitement raison de
le dire des actes illégaux
donc jamais
jamais alors que lui ait des convictions
et que d'ailleurs il est un moment
décidé dans sa vie politique pour les
mettre en oeuvre
de s'affranchir de la solidarité
gouvernementale à l'époque en 2016 et
d'être candidat à la présidente de la
République ça c'est une autre chose sont
séchoirs et les Français l'ont j'ai
l'impression plutôt plutôt suivi mais
jamais il n'a exercé cette pression il a
défendu des convictions il a respecté
les les arbitrages et je répète je
n'étais pas éloigné de ce qui se passait
à l'Assemblée nationale malheureusement
parfois très présent au sein du groupe
socialiste et pour une partie était en
conflit ouvert avec avec mon
gouvernement donc j'étais très très
présent mais je vous parle honnêtement
alors parfois des pertes de mémoire mais
au sein du groupe socialiste où je me
rendais
toutes les semaines sinon deux fois par
semaine le mardi le mercredi j'assistais
évidemment aux questions au gouvernement
les deux jours jamais sur ce sujet là
je n'ai eu peut-être que Laurent
ganguillaume éclaira mieux que moi cette
discussion le sentiment qu'on cherchait
à nous contourner d'une manière ou d'une
je ne veux pas réécrire
l'histoire maintenant ça serait facile
pour moi mais je ne veux pas parce que
je veux rester au plus près du sentiment
ou de la vérité qui était
qui était ressenti à ce à ce moment-là
vous avez fait allusion à
Marseille
et
ce qui s'est passé en octobre 2015
sujet a été évoqué aussi peut-être avec
Bernard Cazeneuve
la préfecture de police de Marseille
[Musique]
que l'arrêté qu'il a pris a été modifié
afin d'être rendu plus restrictif en
s'appliquant sur un plus vaste
territoire et en ciblant plus d'acteurs
que la seule application
uberx l'application qui avait succédé à
uberpop mise en oeuvre toujours par la
société Hubert donc il s'agissait en
l'occurrence d'éviter les fraudes et le
contournement de la réglementation
qu'il avait pu observer lors des
contrôles qui étaient mis en je reprends
cet exemple pour dire que précisément
il me semble que nous n'avons pas cédé
assez assez pression bien au contraire
je
pourrais avoir une position à l'époque
tranchée qu'on peut aussi avoir
aujourd'hui qui serait l'interdiction de
toutes ces pratiques
ce qui poserait sans doute des problèmes
constitutionnels et juridiques
sérieux pas dans ce secteur seulement
mais dans toute une série de secteurs
que ces secteurs là dans les grandes
villes notamment
nécessite une régulation au niveau
européen comme au niveau national une
lutte acharnée contre des pratiques
illégales et insupportables
une vision des travailleurs et des
salariés que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter à l'évidence et je ne sais pas
quelle sera exactement la fin de
l'histoire
de l'encontre que nous vivons
dans une économie ouverte et qu'un
marché unique européen mais qui doit
être régulé il est là le grand débat
c'est toujours celui de la régulation
donc et dans ce débat là il y a des
positions qui peuvent être différentes
je le rappelais pour les pays européens
sur plus ou moins de régulation
ça c'est le débat pour pour
l'avenir mais ça débat qui me semble
très intéressant d'ailleurs le débat
politique et démocratique qui a lieu en
permanence je réponds enfin à votre
question sur
la loi Sapin de bref sur les
recommandations qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer les choses
à l'époque
moi comme ministre et tous ceux qui
auraient
aussi les principaux collaborateurs du
Président de la République et enfin ce
dernier nous avons été marqués je parle
en termes de pratique
par
la dérive de l'un des nôtres
qui a fait énormément de mal au non
seulement à l'exécutif mais au monde
politique pour des raisons je sais pas
à développer ici tellement elles sont
évidentes et puis le Parlement il y
avait travaillé lui aussi
mais suite à cela il y a une loi qui a
été adoptée
parfois elle critiqué d'ailleurs par les
politiques eux-mêmes qu'il avait voté
mais pas seulement une loi
une institution la Haute Autorité la
transparence de la vie publique qu'il a
fait vivre et qui développe une doctrine
sinon même une jurisprudence parfois en
fonction des cas aujourd'hui ces règles
sont lourdes et contraignantes aussi
bien pour les poissons politiques pour
les hauts fonctionnaires elle s'applique
pendant trois ans après la cessation des
fonctions il y a des obligations de
déport
si des dispositions doivent être
améliorées
durci rendu encore plus transparente
personnellement j'ai une voix aucun
inconvénient donc il faut jamais avoir
peur de la probité de la transparence
dans ce domaine là donc elle peut être
et s'il faut être très vigilant sur
l'application de la loi Sapin
qui concerne l'exécutif comme pour les
parlementaires
mais je termine avec une réflexion
peut-être plus générale parce que votre
question pointe nécessaire indépendance
des convictions de l'acteur public
politique ou administratif
je m'interroge toujours sans mettre en
cause à ce que je viens de dire bien au
contraire
toujours sur le fait que au fond comment
on trace
la frontière de la manière la plus
logique possible du moment où le besoin
de contact pour comprendre les intérêts
en présence et de trouver le point
d'équilibre de l'intérêt général se
transforme en risque d'influence
illégitime par des lobbies c'est un
moi j'ai jamais cédé me semble-t-il des
lobbies j'ai mes convictions comme les
reprocher mais c'est ainsi mais dans une
économie ouverte avec autant d'acteurs
je reconnais que le point d'équilibre
n'est jamais facile à trouver d'une
certaine manière vos questions et nos
discussions
l'illustre notamment pour un quelqu'un
qui est en charge un secteur pour un
pour un ministre ou un parlementaire qui
cherche à comprendre ce qui est en train
de se de se passer alors il y a des
règles très claires concernant le lobby
encore une fois elles peuvent être
améliorées on voit bien que au Parlement
européen ce débat existe depuis
très très longtemps il y a en plus selon
les pays des pratiques totalement
différentes je me rappelle il y a déjà
de très nombreuses années
voire été invités comme d'autres députés
français
participer à une séance de la Chambre
des communes et à me rendre à Londres le
Parlement britannique sa partie nouvelle
est totalement organisée pour accueillir
ces lobbies au nom de la transparence
d'ailleurs au nom de la transparence
c'était le cas aussi au Parlement
européen que je ne que je ne connais pas
je ne défends pas du tout c'est pratique
mais
au contraire des règles et de la
transparence sont indispensables mais je
reconnais aussi que parfois
les lignes se brouillent
monsieur le Premier ministre je vous
remercie infiniment pour le temps que
vous nous avez accordé je dois mettre
fin à cette à cette audition parce que
nous allons enchaîner directement sur
une édition du commissaire européen à
l'emploi et le droit sociaux donc nous
allons évoquer les débats de régulation
européen auxquelles vous venez de faire
allusion dans votre conclusion je vous
remercie du temps que vous nous avez
accordé votre témoignage les réponses à
nos questions nous auront peut-être des
questions complémentaires que nous
pourrons vous faire parvenir et bien sûr
vous même n'hésitez pas à nous faire
parvenir des des compléments de réponse
ou d'analyse sur sur tous ces sujets si
vous le souhaitez à la commission
d'enquête nous avons encore à peu près
deux mois de travaux devant nous mais
dans l'intervalle je vous remercie et je
vous souhaite une excellente journée